Hello, and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
I'm your host, David Flanagan, although you probably
know me from across the Internet and this
channel as Rawkode.
Today is our first video in a new
series called Rawkode deep dives.
I wanna thank our sponsor, Commodore,
who have kindly sponsored my time to put
this first deep dive together.
Thank you, Commodore.
This deep dive is on Kubernetes
scheduling.
Now we will start off with a few
of the basics just to set the scene,
but we're gonna move pretty quickly into parts
of the scheduler
that you may not be familiar with.
These are parts of the scheduler that become
more important as your cluster size grows as
your cluster grows by number of pods and
number of nodes.
We've got a lot to cover today,
so let's dive right in. Okay.
So before we move on to the deep
dive content,
let's just understand
on the simplest level
what the scheduler is responsible for.
So here I have a Lima virtual machine
running on my machine,
which provisions a standard kubeadmin cluster.
Now kubeadmin
clusters
have static manifests that run the control plane
component.
Let's not delete it, but let's move
our scheduler to the temp directory.
And what's gonna happen,
probably already happened,
is this
matter matter pod for the scheduler has been
removed.
Now this just means
that if we run get pods,
we'll see the things that are running continue
to run.
But let's try and schedule
a new pod.
Here, I have the simplest pod spec that
we can deploy to our cluster,
and this is just applying NGINX and doesn't
specify anything else.
We can use Vim
to drop this in
and we can kubectl apply
for our cluster.
Now when we run get pods,
we'll see that our NGINX
is in a pending
status.
I'm not sure why Lima is running in
NGINX, but I'm gonna let it go.
Now because we removed
the scheduler,
this will never schedule.
In fact, we can do describe pod nginx,
and you don't really get any error messages.
But if we scroll to here or look
here, we'll see that the node is none,
which is why the status is pending.
Now let's look at our get pods again.
Let's bring back our scheduler
to the static manifest directory.
We'll run get pods on all namespaces.
We'll see our scheduler has now been running
for six seconds, and not only that, but
our NGINX pod was scheduled.
We run describe on it one more time,
we'll see we have a node
and the status is running.
So
in a naive way, we can say the
scheduler's one job in this entire world
is to populate pod specs with a node
name.
That is all.
However, there is a lot of complexity
in how the scheduler determines
what that node name should be.
That is what we're gonna dive into today.
So the first thing we're going to address
is bypassing the scheduler.
Why?
Well,
sometimes you just gotta do what you just
gotta do.
We're now looking at a real Kubernetes cluster.
This time it's hosted on Google Cloud with
JKE.
I'm gonna copy one of these node names,
this time being x 42
using the abbreviation at the end of this
tuple,
and I'm gonna go to our pod spec.
We can drop the node name in on
the spec and just like so,
and this is 100%
valid.
We can either a cube control apply pod,
and if we run get pods dash o
wide so that we can see the node
that it's running on,
We'll see that it's running on x 42.
Now the scheduler doesn't do anything in this
case because the node name is already provided
by me, the operator or developer.
When that node name is missing, the scheduler
kicks in and plays a whole bunch of
rules and heuristics to determine where to schedule
each node.
Let's delete
our pod.
The
next way is scheduling a pod, we're going
to take a look at is through the
node selector.
Now in order to use a node selector,
you have to understand your nodes a little
bit more.
So we're going to run kubectl
describe
node
and paste in our node name.
Now this returns a lot of information, but
what we want to look at are the
labels at the top.
So you can see here that this node
has a name,
has a role of which is none in
this case,
but it has a whole bunch of labels.
We have a label that tells us the
architecture of the machine, in this case, it's
AMD sixty four.
We are also able to get some more
information from the cloud, like the instance type,
this one being an e two medium.
This also tells us the operating system is
Linux.
We then have a bunch of Google Cloud
labels telling us about the boot disk, the
container runtime,
CPU scaling level, log in variant, max pods
per node, node pool, OS distribution, machine family,
and private node.
We then have some failure domain information.
This allows us to schedule things across different
zones within a region and we'll take a
look at that in just a little bit.
Now the one we're going to use just
now to play with the node selector,
it's Kubernetes IO
slash Arch.
As we approach more and more clusters
that aren't homogenous,
they're heterogeneous.
We have clusters with AMD architecture
and ARM architecture.
You may even have machines with GPUs for
machine learning and artificial intelligence.
So we need the ability using the node
selector
to give the scheduler a clue that some
workloads are not like others, and we have
to be a bit more specific about where
we schedule them.
So let's go back to our pods pack.
And instead of setting the node name, we'll
say node selector.
And now I'm going to use those labels
that we've seen earlier.
The one I'm interested in
is beta.kubernetes.io/arch.
Now that all the nodes in my cluster
are AMD 64 like Copilot is suggesting.
However,
let's break this and say that this workload
can only run on ARM 64 machine.
We can now pop back over to the
terminal and do kubectl apply
pod.
Now when we run get pods,
we'll see that this is pending.
We can describe our pod
and we get this nice message at the
bottom.
The scheduler is telling us that it failed
to schedule.
It was the three nodes that are available,
none of them match the constraints that we
specified.
So let's change this.
So let's apply this again.
We run
get pods
and it's running.
Alright. Let's do one more thing with the
node scheduler.
The node selector doesn't just take one parameter.
This works very much like match labels on
your deployment spec. You can add as many
as you want.
So let's remove the beta to Kubernetes.io
slash OS
of Linux.
So now we need a Linux machine
on an AMD sixty four chip.
We can now apply this
from get pods,
and it's running.
So the node selector is a really great
way to take those labels of the knowledge
and understanding the context that we have about
the nodes within our cluster
and move our workloads around as required.
We're not enforcing too many constraints. We're not
being very specific about how it works or
lives with other pods within our cluster, but
we're gonna get to that in just a
second.
The notes later is pretty easy to grok.
You have labels.
You have pods,
match them together.
Sometimes when scheduling pods,
you need a little bit more logic than
just basic label selectors,
and that's where node affinity comes in.
So before we take a look at node
affinity, I'm going to run kubectl get nodes.
Only this time, I'm going to add show
labels.
And these are all the labels that we
can use as part of the node selector
or node affinity configuration.
We'll see here that I have a machine
using the topology labels
in Europe north one a,
Europe North 1 c,
and Europe
North 1 b.
Let's jump back to our pod spec.
And this time, we're gonna specify
affinity.
And we're gonna use
Node Affinity.
And you can see Copilot is jumping straight
ahead here, but I'm just gonna let it
complete and we'll run through it quickly.
Now when it comes to Node Affinity, there
are two keys
that can be used.
There is
preferred during scheduling,
ignored during execution, and required during scheduling,
ignored during execution.
Let's come back to preferred
in just a moment.
Now required during scheduling and ignored during execution
just means that the constraints that we specify
must be true
at the time the pod is scheduled.
Remember,
Kubernetes is eventually consistent through and through.
Labels can change over time.
Just because a pod ends up on a
node now
doesn't mean the labels that were used for
that scheduling decision will still be true in
five minutes, five days, or five months.
Hopefully, your pods aren't running for five months.
Now
affinities are very much like node selectors. We're
still going to be using labels,
but we have the ability to apply operators
in multiple values
rather than just basic 100%
match.
So you'll see here that we have the
node selector terms
and the ability to match expressions.
I'm going to replace this
with a label that we copied earlier.
However, I'll remove the value and remove the
equals,
and we'll say that we want any value
in
Europe North 1 A
and Europe North 1 B.
Let's apply this to our cluster.
And you'll see here that our pod was
scheduled on X 42,
which is Europe North 1 A.
Let's delete and apply again.
We got the same node.
Let's try it one more time for the
last.
Oh, well.
Let's mix it up a bit.
Let's change our constraint to only accept b
and c.
We'll delete and apply.
And now we're scheduled on F Zed F
9.
This
is North 1 C.
So using node affinities,
we can do a match expressions
using the same labels from the node selector,
the ability to select an operator
and work with multiple values. So let's make
a change to one of these operators.
Currently, are scheduled to North 1 C.
So instead of doing in
North 1 C,
let's say not in.
Now we can jump back to our terminal,
delete and apply,
and now we're back on North 1 A.
What operators are available? Well, we have the
ability to do does not exist, exist, greater
than, in, less than, and not in.
So enough operators to cover most of the
basic scheduling constraints that you would that you
would want to apply to your workload.
Now in the interest of this being a
deep dive and being complete, I will also
add the match expressions isn't the only option.
We also have the ability to match on
fields.
Like so.
Now this isn't a feature that you're likely
to use unless you're scheduling a daemon set
on a subset of nodes within your cluster.
The reason is is that is that the
labels we have on a node include the
host name, but the host name isn't always
your node name.
So this match fields was added purely for
that case,
and really the only key you can actually
match on is the metadata dot name.
So I've covered it. You don't really need
it.
You can just forget about it.
Let's move on. So as I said, we
have required during scheduling,
but also preferred during scheduling.
So let's set this now.
This time, I'll let Copilot
do its thing.
We're gonna come back up here
and use the Kubernetes IO arch
label.
Now we know this cluster has no arch
60 fours,
so let's drop that in.
Now we'll go back to the terminal
and apply our pod.
What do you think is gonna happen?
We have no arch 64
nodes.
However, when we run get pods,
our container was scheduled.
And that's because while the scheduler couldn't find
a node that was a complete match,
It was just a preference,
so it settled for another.
Now you can chain lots of these together
and set multiple preferences
and increase the weight from one to 100
depending
on how much you favor each preference.
Okay. So we're taking a look at node
affinities.
Now let's take a look at pod affinities.
What's the difference?
Well, node affinity allows us to say that
a workload should run on these nodes with
these constraints.
Pod affinities
allow us to take that one step further.
Now we can say that we want this
pod to run as close to these pods
or these pods to run as far away
from those pods.
This gives us the ability to repel
or co locate pods within our infrastructure.
Why would we want to do that?
Well, if you have components within a mission
critical system,
it's likely you won't want to schedule them
on the same node
because nodes go away.
Nodes fail.
And if your node fails, do you really
want to lose multiple multiple components of a
mission critical system?
We have to minimize the blast radius of
the collateral damage when we lose a node.
On the other hand, if performance is something
that you're more sensitive to, it could be
that you want your customer facing API as
close to your database as possible to minimize
latency and network hops around your infrastructure.
So we'd use affinity to colocate and anti
affinity to repel.
Let's take a look at this by example.
Here, I have four pod specifications.
I have a pod called NGINX East one,
NGINX East two,
and NGINX West one, and NGINX West two.
They're very creative, I know.
We're gonna set up some pod affinities to
schedule the East pods as close to each
other as possible and the West pods as
close to each other as possible.
And we won't bother with anti affinity just
yet.
So we're gonna come into our pod spec
and we use the affinity key.
And now we can see that we actually
want pod
affinity.
And I'll let Copilot drop this straight on,
but we'll walk right through it.
Now the first thing we need to do
is configure our label selector.
The label selector is a bit different from
the node selector this time
because we're using the selector
to group the pods with the shared affinity.
Which pods
do we want to run as close to
each other as possible? Now Copilot's already guessed
exactly what I was gonna do here,
which is to match on the names
and say that we want to group east
one and east two
together.
The last part of this pod affinity is
the topology key,
and all this is doing is telling us
which label on the node to use as
a grouping.
So when we match these pods together, we
want to ensure that they all end up
in the same zone,
which is why we're using
the filler domain beta Kubernetes IO zone.
Of course, if we describe our nodes
or show labels,
We could also use this topology code here
if we wanted to do this regionally,
or we could use the zone code here.
And instead of using the filler domain,
let's use topology Kubernetes zone.
So let's copy this affinity,
apply it here too,
and we'll do the same for West, only
this time we'll update
the West keys,
like so.
Let's apply our four pods to the cluster.
Now what we should see is that the
two east pods are scheduled in the same
zone and the two west pods are scheduled
in the same zone.
But right now,
that zone could be the same for all
four pods
because we haven't built any repel or anti
affinity
into the two different pod specs.
So let's see where they all ended up.
Alright.
West is on F Zed, and East is
on X 42.
So updating these pod manifests
is a little painful.
So let's delete them for the last time.
And now let's work with some deployment objects
that we can scale up and down
to see how these affinities and anti affinities
work in a slightly larger scale.
So let's take a look at our new
deployment specs.
Here we have an NGINX East deployment
replicas 10 with a pod affinity
to group all of its pods together
on the same host.
Down here, we have NGINX West replicas 10
with the same affinity to group all of
NGINX West pods together
on the same host.
We can apply this to our cluster,
run get pods, and we'll see the containers
are creating.
Let's run that again and hope it's been
enough time to get the output of white.
We'll see 10 pods on f zed f
for nginx west
and 10 pods on x 42
for nginx east.
So we've removed NGINX East and West,
and we're trying to represent something that is
a more traditional three tier application setup.
Here, we have some sort of critical application.
This could be your front end proxy, like
h a proxy, NGINX, whatever you're using to
deliver cached assets to your customers.
It's very likely you never want this to
fall over because then your customers aren't getting
aren't
getting their responses.
So we're gonna call it critical app a.
Next, we have web app a. This is
the back end for the critical app.
So if we can't deliver something from a
cache, we have to go speak to the
back end service
and deliver the result. We're gonna call this
web app a,
and web app a needs to speak to
a database. So we have database a.
My name, it sucks.
So we have our three tier application setup.
Now all of these containers are just NGINX
under the hood. It's not important.
We're just looking at the scheduling constraints.
So in a production like environment, what do
we need to do?
Well, we're very concerned about the performance of
our web applications speaking to our database.
So let's do something that we already know
how to do
and couple these together through affinity.
Well, let's go to our affinity.
We'll do pod affinity.
We'll let Copilot drop in some things.
And what we're going to say here
is that we want to schedule web apps
next to database apps,
and we want them on the same host
name.
Doesn't matter where the databases end up.
We're only gonna set the affinity on the
web app. So whenever those come to be
scheduled,
we always find a node or hopefully always
find a node where there is a database
product available
to couple those together.
Let's apply this to our cluster
and run get pods.
Now we can see we have two copies
of the critical app are on f zed
f and x 42.
Our database ended up on x 42,
which means our two web apps ended up
on x 42.
So let's increase the replicas for our web
application.
Now let's say we need 10.
Where do you think they're gonna end up?
Well, let's run get pods
await,
and we're now starting to heavily overload our
x 42 server.
Why?
Because it's the only place we have a
scheduled database,
and the pod affinity rules mandate that all
of those web application pods should run on
the same host name.
So let's horizontally scale our database application.
And I'm gonna scale back our web application
at the same time just so that we
can scale it back up to see even
distribution
across more than one node.
And we'll scale up our database
to be three.
Now when we run get pods,
drags,
we have three databases running on the same
node.
That's not ideal.
So now we need to do something else.
We have our web applications matched in Affinity
with the database nodes.
Our two critical applications got schedules on different
nodes by chance,
and our three database nodes got scheduled together
by chance on the same node. And I'm
not a big fan of by chance in
a Kubernetes environment.
So we need to apply anti affinities
to our database and our critical application.
So we can come back in and add
the affinity key
and say that we want pod anti affinity.
We're now going to say, thank you, Copilot,
that all of our critical applications, which is
all the apps with a label
app with value critical app a,
will be repelled
from the host name.
That means when we schedule
three of these critical applications,
we will see one on each node within
the cluster.
In fact, we'll take that a step further
and we'll request four.
Now because we have a required during scheduling,
we'll see that one critical web app is
actually gonna fail to schedule.
While I'm here, I'm also gonna copy this
affinity block for our database.
We will update the value here, the database
a,
and it's the exact same rule.
We never want to schedule two databases on
the same node because
we need these to be resilient across node
failures.
And we'll say that we want three replicas,
one on each node.
Well, let's take a look where these all
ended up.
We can see now that we have three
copies of our database,
all on three different nodes.
We can see that our critical app actually
can't schedule right now, and that's because we
are in a small cluster with pod anti
affinities.
So they're actually never gonna be able to
schedule.
We can help that along by deleting the
old replica set like so.
And now we can see our web applications
are both still scheduled on the same node.
So let's kick some and see where they
end up.
And now they're on different nodes because they
have multiple options,
because we have multiple availabilities of the database
pod.
Perfect.
And as we said, with critical apps, and
at four replicas and three nodes with the
anti affinity,
we have one pod which we'll never schedule.
So pod affinities and especially anti affinities
are great resources
for increasing the resiliency of your application in
a Kubernetes environment.
With the caveat that you have to be
aware
of those scheduling constraints and the size of
your cluster.
And a three node setup like I'm working
with right now, it's gonna be very difficult
to roll out updates to your application
because there may not be enough nodes to
satisfy those constraints.
So let's tweak this example a little bit
more.
Now we have just two deployments,
a critical web app, which we need three
of, and it has an anti affinity against
itself
and the database.
Why the database?
Well, in the case of node failure, we
don't want our database and our critical web
app to be unavailable.
We then have our database, which has an
anti affinity on itself because we need resiliency
at the database layer.
When applied together in this configuration,
we end up with this.
We have the three database pods scheduled and
running.
However, we're unable
to schedule a critical application.
Why? Because the database anti affinity with itself
spreads out across all the nodes in our
cluster.
The critical app has an anti affinity of
the database, so now it can't schedule anywhere
where the database is running, which just happens
to be
everywhere.
And we have a tool for this too
through priority
classes.
Let's jump back over to our YAML and
create a new YAML document.
We can copy an example from a documentation
like so.
Here, we're using the scheduling Kubernetes IOV one
API.
We're going to create a new priority class,
and we'll call this
critical.
We set this value
very, very high because it has to rank
higher than the other priority classes within the
system.
We do not want to use this as
a global default. All our applications are not
critical.
And then you can add a description for
any operator that comes along as curious what
this priority class is for.
There's just one other flag on this resource
that isn't covered with this first example,
and that is the preemption policy.
Now I'm gonna set it to never,
but there is another option.
How do we know what these options are?
Well, we can rely on our good friend,
kubectl explain.
With kubectl explain, you can put in any
resource name and then any member of that
spec
to get detailed documentation about how it could
be configured.
Now we can see that the preemption policy
allows us to be never or
preempt lower priority.
Now all preemption means is that when new
pods come into the queue to be scheduled,
we can take a look at the value
of the priority class
to understand if they should skip the queue.
If we leave this as a default
when a critical pod needs to be scheduled,
plus there's 12 pods in front of it,
it's likely the scheduler will say, hey. I
have to go schedule this one first.
Kinda like being friends with a bouncer in
an eight clip.
And if you don't want this behavior in
your cluster,
set the policy to never,
and pods of this class will never skip
the queue.
So let's add this priority class to our
deployment.
We pop down to the pod spec where
we can set the priority class name to
critical.
So let's set up a scenario where we
can see that in action.
We'll take off the never so we can
get the default, which is to preempt the
pods ahead of the queue.
I'm going to comment out a critical app
and scale our database
to six.
Now
we can run get pods.
We'll see that we have three database pods
pending and three database pods running.
Currently, we have three pods and the queue
to be scheduled.
Let's bring back our priority class
and our critical application.
We make sure that our priority class name
is set on our deployment object.
Now when we apply these and run get
pods,
we'll see that our critical application
didn't just skip the queue,
It evicted the other database pods.
Priority classes give you a lot of power
when it comes to scheduling workloads within your
cluster.
Just be careful you don't blow away other
important aspects at the same time.
Alright.
Let's kick things up a little bit and
start playing with some more advanced scheduling techniques.
So there's a relatively new feature in Kubernetes
called topology spread constraints.
Try saying that three times fast.
Topology spread constraints allow us
to scale up our application
while maintaining even distribution
across a dimension.
That dimension could be region, host, architecture,
whatever you want,
and we have options to configure the maximum
skew for that even distribution.
Mean and allow meaning that we allow
a certain deviation
of that spread across the dimension
based on what we configure.
Now I know that all sounds like blah
blah blah blah blah,
so we're gonna walk through an example of
that step by step to really help solidify
what spread topology constraints are.
So I set up a situation
where we have three database pods and three
critical application pods.
We still have the anti affinity, so the
critical app cannot be scheduled to anywhere there
is a database pod.
If we take a look at the YAML,
we've added our topology spread constraint.
Now we're gonna come back to that in
just a minute.
The first thing I want to do is
scale down our database,
giving us a little bit of room to
deploy
a critical application
pod.
Now what's important to hear,
there is no anti affinity
on a critical application.
We only specify anti affinity against the database.
So you'd maybe expect that we're able to
deploy all three critical application pods
to
the one zone which we're using as a
topology key.
Now because we have the spread topology constraint,
this actually cannot be scheduled,
specifically
because we say that if we cannot satisfy
this constraint,
we don't want to schedule any new pods.
So let's work through
the topology spread configuration.
The first thing we do is we apply
a label selector.
So you could use this to enforce even
distribution
of multiple deployments, replica sets, stateful sets, etcetera,
any pod from any higher level component
if you need to enforce even distribution.
You can set the topology key.
Here, we're using host name.
So what I'm saying is that when I
schedule pods with app critical app a, I
want even distribution with every node across every
node in my cluster.
And the max skew of one means I'm
only willing to accept
one host,
one node,
and one pod
above the even distribution.
Does that make sense?
Let's break it down a bit more.
Let's set the max skew to two.
When we run get pods, we'll see that
we have two critical apps now being scheduled,
and they're both going to be on the
same machine,
f zed f, the only node that doesn't
have a database pod and doesn't violate the
anti affinity.
Now we don't have even distribution because we
have three nodes,
but we have two pods on one node.
Even distribution would mean one pod or one
pod on each node.
And with a skew of one, meaning maybe
one node could push to two.
I know it can be a little complicated.
So let's set the skew back to one
and drop our database to one.
Now when we run get pods,
we have two
being scheduled,
and even distribution will be maintained.
We're going to see one of these on
each pod,
each node that is available that doesn't have
a database.
So let's take the database out altogether now
and apply.
Now
we have one critical application
across each node. We have complete
even distribution right now, meaning
one on each of the dimension, the host
name.
With a skew of one, we can actually
scale this
to four,
and that will be okay. And in fact,
we can push this to 20
and apply.
And this will continue to work
because as long as the scheduler can have
even distribution,
meaning it can schedule
ubiquitously across the dimension,
we have no problems.
So let's bring back
our database node
with one.
We're going to delete our deployment.
Like so.
This puts us back in a position
where we have one database
once it finally schedules.
There we go.
And now we're gonna bring back
our topology spread aware deployment.
So we'll set this to three
and apply.
You'll see that one fails to schedule.
Why does it work this way?
Well, if we're if we're able to schedule
evenly across the dimension, which is host name
here,
and we have the ability to schedule on
all the host names,
then the skew never
goes above zero and you can scale the
workload as much as you want.
When you lose access
to one of the nodes on the dimension
or the node in this dimension,
we're going to then have uneven distribution
across the dimension,
which means this skew becomes very important.
Now, of course, I could say that I
want a skew of 10
and I can scale this deployment back up
as much as I want because we can
accept 10 nodes across breaking the deviation.
But it's likely that you want even distribution
for a reason.
We'll apply it back to one.
So when should you use topology spread constraint?
Well, it's kind of an evolution of anti
affinity.
Let's assume that you want to decrease the
latency
or minimize egress traffic across zones and regions
within your cluster
or latency to your customers.
You could use anti affinity to ensure that
you schedule the pods in different regions and
zones,
But the the anti affinity means that you
can't then continue to scale up those pods
within that region without adding new nodes.
Spread topology constraints
mean that we can continue to scale up
a workload
while ensuring the even distribution.
We could be in a position where we
want 20 or 50 replicas of a pod.
This could all be scheduled on one machine.
So we add the anti affinity, and now
we need 50 machines.
But, actually, what we really want to do
is just ensure that we have enough
resiliency,
redundancy, and performance benefit
by maintaining even distribution across the zones and
the regions.
So we have the ability
to do anti affinity in a controlled manner
without the ceiling
on the scale or without our scale being
bound by the number of nodes,
and that's pretty cool.
Alright.
Let's kick things up again.
This time, we're venturing so far into new.
This stuff is one twenty six alpha. However,
this is some new, cool scheduling features coming
to Kubernetes
soon.
Now I can't use my shiny managed GKE
cluster for this demo because we do need
to enable
a feature gate on the Kube API server.
If we go into manifest Kube API server,
you'll see that on the feature gate line
here,
I have enabled a feature gate called pod
scheduling
readiness.
What does this mean?
Well, it means I can have a pod
spec,
which has scheduling gates.
This is for situations
where you want to create pods,
but they're not ready to be scheduled yet.
This could be very useful for blue green
and canary style deployments,
where we wanna start pushing resources around, but
we need to get their scheduling.
Why?
Well,
when you have unschedulable pods for whatever reason,
that can trigger your cluster autoscaler,
which can spin up a whole bunch of
new nodes unnecessarily
just because you created a pod that could
never be scheduled,
and it can't be scheduled because it's not
ready to be scheduled yet.
This is where scheduling gates come in.
So let's apply
this to our cluster
and run get pods.
We'll see here that our pod is pending,
and we can describe our pod
and we'll see a nice little message at
the bottom saying that we can't schedule this
because we have a non empty scheduling gates.
We can come in
and remove a gate.
Wow.
You just see me edit a pod.
Typically, pods
are extremely immutable.
However, with scheduling gates, we do have some
mutability on the spec.
Though it's not ever really a situation where
you should be manually
modifying these scheduling gates,
This should be a controller within your cluster.
You should be pushing these pods or these
deployments replica sets should be creating the pods
with the scheduling gates.
And your custom controller, whether that be for
blue green, canary, perhaps it's a phased rollout
across new zones or regions,
whatever
your reasoning is,
your controller
can monitor those gates
and remove them as required.
So then that we've removed the scheduling gates,
we can reapply the pod and it will
be scheduled
as normal.
So this isn't a world changing feature,
but it does open up new levels of
automation in cluster web controllers,
and I'm very excited to see what tooling
does with this new feature.
Alright.
We're gonna kick it up one more time,
and we're gonna straight back in to alpha
features of 01/26.
This is dynamic resource allocation.
What is dynamic resource allocation?
Well,
let's understand everything we've covered so far.
Scheduler,
at least in the earliest days, only allows
you only allowed you to schedule based on
CPU and memory.
Over time, that wasn't good enough for people
deploying to Kubernetes,
and new options were added. The ability to
schedule based on the hardware available,
network topologies,
availability
of volumes, and so forth.
Well, these are all baked pretty much straight
into Kubernetes itself.
Dynamic resource allocation
allows us to dynamically define new things that
can be claimed.
Now the examples focus on
hardware
as part of the node,
like a GPU.
I actually think the use case for this
will go much further,
potentially out to claiming
cloud resources
or maybe locks on topics on Red Panda.
Now it's very early, but I'm gonna show
you what I've been able to put together
for dynamic resource allocation.
Now, of course, when you're venturing in
to the wilds of alpha features, we have
a feature gate called dynamic resource allocation as
well as a runtime config to enable a
new API group of resource.kates.io.
For this example, I did have to provide
my own CRD,
And I'm kind of leaning on the example
from the KEP here, which talks about claiming
cats,
only there wasn't enough code in the KEP
for it to actually deploy,
so I had to fix that.
So here we have a custom resource definition
that describes a cat, and we have a
couple of properties, one properties. One being the
size of the cat and the color of
the cat.
And this is now available
within our cluster
of a grep
for cat.
Ta da.
Next up,
we have
resource.YAML.
Now the first thing you need to do
is provide a driver.
This is something that is responsible
for providing or allocating the claim
and then removing it when a claim is
no longer needed.
So here, we're just making up a driver
name of resourcedriver.example.com,
and we have a resource class to back
them.
Next, I'm creating a cat.
So I'm using the custom resource definition I
put together to describe a cat, which is
large and black.
Then we have a resource claim template.
Much like a PVC,
here I'm saying that I want to be
able to claim
something of this resource class name with these
parameters.
So I'm providing a template for someone who
wants to claim my cat.
So we can now apply this to my
cluster like so.
Now I can run kubectl get
cats,
and I'll see my large black cat.
I can also run resource
claim
template.
My cat can be claimed,
and we're just waiting for the first consumer
who wants my cat.
So let's go back to our pod spec.
Here, we have an NGINX pod,
and that's it.
So let's actually consume our new resource claim.
Much like a PVC, we have to start
by adding our resource claims
to the top of our pod spec.
We can give it a name
and say that that's a Salem,
the name of the cat from my favorite
TV show as a kid, Sabrina.
We can say the source of this claim
is our resource
claim
template
name,
which is large black
cat claim
template.
Now that we have this available,
we can go to a container.
And you see here where we have resources
and limits and CPU already for memory.
We're going to add
that we want
our claims,
and we want our name Salem.
Now we can come to pod.yaml,
drop it in,
and apply.
Now there's no real driver piloting this claim,
so we could run resource
claim
template,
and we'd see that it's still waiting for
the first consumer.
But I hope that shows you how we
can start to bring in new hardware like
the KEP proposes,
but also claims on cloud resources.
And I can't wait to see where this
functionality goes over the next year.
So that's dynamic resource allocation.
So that's it for our deep dive into
Kubernetes scheduling.
We took a look at the basics, scheduling
the node by setting the node name yourself.
We then progressed into node selectors,
affinities,
anti affinities,
topology spread constraints,
and some very fresh out of the oven
features with with dynamic resource allocation
and scheduling games.
So I hope this video was useful to
you. Remember to subscribe and click the thumb
button to thumb up, please.
And I will see you next time. Thank
you again to Commodore for sponsoring my time
to make this video.
I'll see you all next time. Have a
great day.